and that was President Trump wrapping up
questions from the media he responded to
the allegations against Joe Biden his
coronavirus response and to the new
revelations in the case against Michael
Flynn
he talked broadly about all sorts of
things I'm talking about North Korea he
talked about I thought he made a little
bit of news on China and I also thought
if I could have a point of personal
privilege here to say from a
communication standpoint I thought this
press conference was leap yards of so
much better than the ones from the past
couple of weeks the questions were very
good they were on point and the
president showed a lot of empathy and
such knowledge across a broad range of
topics so that's my little point but I
will take it around the table now to get
thoughts from the group here this is
your five we're all here and we have
been listening intently Jesse let me
start with you for any thoughts on any
of the topics that the president brought
up and me he talked about just about
everything he could he zeroed in on
China pretty specifically why were
people in Wuhan not allowed to leave to
the rest of China but allowed to leave
to the rest of the world and infect the
world
China has to answer that question and
they haven't answered that question at
all he also says he has a very high
degree of confidence that the virus came
from this lab in Wuhan that was pretty
interesting and he kind of was
brainstorming about ways to financially
sanction China whether it's tariffs
whether it's debt payments so he does
seem to have seriously changed his tone
from two months ago when he was
complimentary about how the Chinese have
handled it on the heels of the trade
deal - now after learning from the
intelligence community how this thing
escaped and how the world was not warned
about it it looks like it's a whole new
ballgame with the Chinese he also kind
of wandered in to Sweden in Brazil they
tried to do heard and doing heard
doesn't work very well and he came
himself kind of a pat on the back for
locking down this country so strongly
and predicted this is going to be an
ugly second quarter and really bounce
back strongly in the third or
potentially the fourth Greg one of the
questions I thought that was very good
and you might
expected more from in a long-form
interview than in a press conference
like this and it was the the question
was you've said that we are in a war
against the virus so what does victory
look like to you I thought his answer
was measured in pretty empathetic and
long reaching yeah it was pretty good um
you know I think that the media it were
almost four years into this presidency
still fails to understand what Trump is
so the lit the literalness that they
take his optimism he's a machine built
on optimism and I will steal this joke
from someone on Twitter who said he was
officially asked more about Tara Reid
than Joe Biden has been asked which was
funny but I want to bring up due to
Jesse's thing about Trump talking about
the one-sided travel I seem to remember
a dashing good-looking TV anchor on the
5 back in January 27 screaming at the
top of his lungs saying why are people
from China leaving and coming here but
we aren't allowed to go to China I
remember yelling that it was like just
January 27 as if it was yesterday so I'd
like to put my little feather in my
camera too I know I play it over and
over again when I went at home when I'm
alone which is often I would say that
Katie that his answer about Joe Biden
and Tara Reed was was very good and
actually I'm told we have the thought so
let's let's play that in case anybody
missed it this is how it went I don't
know anything about it I don't know
exactly I think he should respond you
know it could be false accusations like
know all about false accusations I've
been falsely charged numerous times and
there is such a thing if you look at if
you look at Brett Kavanaugh there's an
outstanding man he was falsely charged
what happened with him was an absolute
disgrace to a country all right Katie
your thoughts on that I thought it was
definitely answered what do you think
I would agree that it was definitely
answered he didn't attack Joe Biden on
this issue and he put the focus back on
due process and and and answering to the
charges of your accuser publicly
especially when you're running for
president of the United States but also
he puts it on the left and everybody
who's championed this idea that you
should believe every single accusation
without any kind of due process or or
vetting and so you know he puts it the
the standard back on the left by making
them play by their own rules when it
comes to how they want to handle these
situations because they've decided that
they want the standard of you believe
any accusation that any woman makes
against any man because men are somehow
evil and of course they're all engaged
in some kind of sexual abuse towards
women because of the patriarchy but then
you have Joe Biden in the leading
candidate who is now the nominee of the
party who has an accusation that comes
out with Tara Reid with corroboration
from multiple people by the way and they
have a choice to make about whether
they're going to violate their own
standards on this issue they've had for
two years or whether they're going to
move forward with the nominee and one
maybe let me ask you about the news we
found out right before this show that
tomorrow morning Joe Biden is going to
take questions from Morning Joe about
Tara Reid yeah I think we've all advised
that it would be good for the former
vice president to get out there and
address this and even to go into the
records at the University Delaware and
just say here's what exists and here's
what doesn't exist but just to be
transparent Dana just to clear the air I
think that's good for everybody
I think the president was you know quite
careful in terms of his own response by
saying you know he's denied things and
if people on the right who I think in
some cases are trying to exploit this
where political purposes would accept
president Trump's and allocate the
question is then what are you going to
do when Vice President Biden appears on
MSNBC tomorrow and says yeah I deny the
charges does that then settle it in the
way that people who are Trump supporters
accept his denials in the face of you
know tapes and
sign checks and all the rest but I
thought you think about that interested
I think that the more well I mean
there's one section this is someone with
the consensual situation and there was
no payoffs for a sexual assault
allegation that's different
no there's a calling which he denied hey
it's okay then I just wanted to I just
wanted to say that I think there was
news made in terms of the top of it
where the president is talking about
potentially even bringing Michael Flynn
back into the administration on the
basis of some FBI memos that came from
Michael Flynn's lawyers and I think it
was an aggressive leaked by a defense
lawyer that plays to the president's
grievance against the intelligence
community but is specifically against
the FBI and I think it's setting up the
conditions for a presidential pardon
okay can you can you hold for there Greg
did you want to comment on Biden yeah I
think that we're missing a big point
here Biden has a huge disadvantage with
Trump you knew what you were getting
into with Trump sleeping with stormy
Daniels I can see that happening I don't
want to see it but I know that it could
happen but with Biden he you find out
that he's dirty right he's got to defend
it whether it's about banks or
boorishness because he was supposed to
be the moral alternative to Donald Trump
not just for the Democrats but for the
never Trump errs this was going to be
the solution for the bulwark in this
solution for Bill Kristol he was the
moral immoral choice over evil Trump
even though rumors swirled around Joe
Biden for years about his behavior about
his swimming habits you know we knew it
so the thing is this is gonna be a lot
harder for him to deal with than people
think
they just can't say but look at Trump
because he's supposed to be better right
isn't that what we were told